This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. In 1980, Ronald Reagan became president of the United States. He quickly raised the temperature of the Cold War and assumed a muscular stance toward the Soviet Union. Let us be aware that while they preach the supremacy of the state, they are the focus of evil in the modern world. That September, a message flashed in a secret bunker at Supercar 15, a secret Soviet outpost that analyzed satellite data from the United States.
这里是Hidden Brain。我是Shankar Vedantam。1980年，罗纳德·里根就任美国总统。他迅速提高了冷战的紧张局势，并对苏联采取了强硬立场。我们要意识到，尽管他们宣扬国家至上，但他们是现代世界邪恶的中心。那年9月，一条信息在Supercar 15的秘密掩体中闪烁，这是一个分析美国卫星数据的苏联秘密前哨站。
Inside the bunker was a 44-year-old Soviet Lieutenant Colonel named Stanislav Petrov. The military commander saw a button pulsing red. His panel told him the unimaginable had happened. The United States had launched a ballistic missile. Within minutes the satellite data showed four more missiles had been launched. It looked like the United States was trying to cripple the Soviet Union with a sudden deadly nuclear attack. There were only seconds for the Soviets to launch strikes in response. Stanislav Petrov debated whether to report the attack.
掩体里有一位44岁的苏联中校，名叫斯坦尼斯拉夫·彼得罗夫。这位军事指挥官看到一个按钮在闪烁红光。他的控制面板告诉他，不可想象的事情发生了。美国发射了一枚弹道导弹。几分钟内，卫星数据显示又有四枚导弹被发射。看起来美国正试图通过突然的致命核打击来瘫痪苏联。苏联只有几秒钟的时间来发射反击导弹。斯坦尼斯拉夫·彼得罗夫在犹豫是否要报告这次袭击。
If he did, it could have triggered a massive Soviet response. The Soviet commander did not do what was expected of him. He decided the satellite data was wrong and did not report the missiles. He was right. The satellite signals were reflections of sunlight off clouds. You probably have never heard of Stanislav Petrov, but you might owe your life to him. Retaliatory strikes could easily have killed half the populations of both countries. Researchers have estimated that the nuclear winter that followed could have killed 2 billion people worldwide. There is a lesson in the story about where the fallible human beings should ever have nuclear weapons at their disposal. But our focus today is on a psychological idea.
如果他报告了，可能会引发苏联的大规模反击。这位苏联指挥官没有做人们预期他会做的事。他断定卫星数据是错误的，并没有报告导弹。他是对的。卫星信号是阳光在云层上的反射。你可能从未听说过斯坦尼斯拉夫·彼得罗夫，但你可能欠他一条命。报复性打击很容易导致两国一半人口死亡。研究人员估计，随之而来的核冬天可能会导致全球20亿人死亡。这个故事给我们的教训是，脆弱的人类是否应该掌握核武器。但我们今天关注的是一个心理学概念。
How our minds work when we are under attack. It's also the start of a series we're calling US 2.0. As we begin what promises to be a pivotal and contentious election season in the United States and many countries around the world, we're taking a close look at how we engage with our opponents. Over the next few weeks we'll explore the assumptions we make about our allies and our foes. We look to history for lessons and we'll offer specific strategies to engage constructively with our opponents, whether in the political realm, at the dinner table or at work.
当我们受到攻击时，我们的思维是如何运作的。这也是我们称之为“美国2.0”系列节目的开篇。随着美国和世界许多国家进入一个注定关键且充满争议的选举季，我们正在密切关注我们如何与对手互动。在接下来的几周里，我们将探讨我们对盟友和对手所做的假设。我们将从历史中汲取教训，并提供具体的策略，以便在政治领域、餐桌上或工作中与对手进行建设性的接触。
We begin with the psychology of threat, this week on Hidden Brain. When something bad happens, it's human nature to look for someone to blame. Needless to say, that person usually isn't us. The tendency to see others as villains and to cast ourselves as innocent victims causes harm in interpersonal relationships. It may also lie beneath some of our deepest societal divides. At the University of North Carolina, psychologist and neuroscientist Kurt Gray studies what happens in our minds
本周在Hidden Brain，我们从威胁心理学开始。当坏事发生时，寻找替罪羊是人的本性。不用说，那个人通常不是我们自己。将他人视为恶棍并将自己塑造成无辜受害者的倾向，会损害人际关系。它也可能潜藏在我们一些最深层的社会分歧之下。在北卡罗来纳大学，心理学家兼神经科学家库尔特·格雷研究了我们的思维会发生什么
when we think about our political opponents. Kurt Gray, welcome to Hidden Rain. Thanks so much for having me on. Kurt, I want to start our conversation with a story that is very far away from politics, but I think it has a deep connection with politics at a psychological level. When you were a teenager, you used to drive around with a bunch of high school
当我们思考政治对手时。库尔特·格雷，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。非常感谢邀请我参加。库尔特，我想从一个远离政治的故事开始我们的谈话，但我认为它在心理层面上与政治有着深刻的联系。当你十几岁的时候，你经常和一群高中
friends. I understand your car was nicknamed Fireball. Does that say something about how fast you used to drive? It does. I used to drive a two-door Pontiac Grand Am. It wasn't a flashy car, but I liked to drive it very fast and didn't always pay attention. So one time you and your friends were heading to a movie when something fairly dramatic happened to you. Tell me the story of what happened, Kurt. I was 16, had just got my license,
朋友开车到处转。我听说你的车绰号叫“火球”。这是否说明你以前开车有多快？确实。我以前开一辆双门庞蒂亚克Grand Am。它不是一辆显眼的车，但我喜欢开得很快，而且并不总是注意路况。所以有一次你和朋友们在去电影院的路上，发生了一些相当戏剧性的事情。告诉我们发生了什么，库尔特。我当时16岁，刚拿到驾照，
and we were driving in the night to go see a movie and it had just rained. And so the streets were shining in the orange sodium lights and we were roaring up the road because the movie started in five minutes and we were 10 minutes away. And I was in the right-hand lane. There was a lane to my left. And my friend in shotgun
我们正开车去电影院，刚下过雨。街道在橙色的钠灯下闪闪发光，我们正沿着路飞驰，因为电影五分钟后就开始了，而我们还有10分钟的路程。我在右侧车道。我左边有一条车道。坐在副驾驶的朋友
all of a sudden said, Kurt, you're going to miss the turn, turn left. And so I hauled on the steering wheel to the left. I didn't look in the lane next to me because I had to cross the lane to be able to turn left. And there was a car driving next to me. Oh my gosh. So as I turned, this car slammed on its brakes. I suddenly became aware it was there. I slammed on my brakes. We screeched and squealed,
突然说，库尔特，你要错过转弯了，向左转。于是我猛地向左打方向盘。我没有看旁边的车道，因为我必须穿过那条车道才能左转。而旁边正有一辆车在行驶。天哪。所以当我转弯时，那辆车猛踩刹车。我突然意识到它的存在。我也猛踩刹车。我们发出刺耳的尖叫声，
the roads were wet. So we spun around in the intersection. I didn't hit it, this other car, it didn't hit me and we didn't hit anything else. So luckily, everyone was safe. No one was around. We ended up stopped in the wrong direction on the other side of the road, just kind of in a desolate night.
路面很湿。所以我们在十字路口打转。我没有撞到它，那辆车也没有撞到我，我们也没有撞到其他任何东西。所以幸运的是，大家都平安无事。周围没有人。我们最终停在路对面，方向反了，就在一个荒凉的夜晚。
I mean, it's still a heart-stopping moment though, because I think in that instant, everyone must have seen how close they came to a crash. It was terrifying and it happened so fast. I mean, the music was so loud, right? We barely realized anything. We were kind of wrapped in our own world. And so I open my window to start to apologize to the driver of the other car. It was a Silver Mercedes Benz. And this driver, this guy gets out of the car. He was in his early 20s, had pretty nice clothes on.
我的意思是，那仍然是一个令人心跳停止的时刻，因为我认为在那一瞬间，每个人一定都看到了他们离撞车有多近。那太可怕了，而且发生得太快了。我的意思是，音乐声太大了，对吧？我们几乎没意识到任何事情。我们沉浸在自己的世界里。所以我打开车窗准备向另一辆车的司机道歉。那是一辆银色的梅赛德斯奔驰。然后这个司机，这个家伙从车里出来。他20出头，穿着相当不错的衣服。
I remember he had curly hair, it was gelled. He had some silver chains on. And I just started opening my mouth to say sorry. And he looks at me just daggers, right? In his eyes and his shoulders are set and he is coming towards me fast and he says, you're dead. Get out of the car. I'm gonna kill you. Kurt was terrified. He stepped on the gas and took off. To his horror, the driver of the Mercedes hurried back to his car, jumped in it, and came off to him.
我记得他留着卷发，抹了发胶。他戴着一些银链子。我刚张开嘴想说对不起。他看着我，眼神像刀子一样，对吧？他的眼神和肩膀紧绷，他正快速向我走来，他说，你死定了。下车。我要杀了你。库尔特吓坏了。他猛踩油门逃走了。令他惊恐的是，梅赛德斯司机匆忙回到车里，跳进去，追了上来。
So I took off and I was flying through a strip malls. It was a really built-up kind of like big box store kind of area. I was totally panicked. I had no idea where it was going. And so, and again, it was dark. It was no one was around. Even though the movie theater, you know, half a mile away was. It was no one was around, even though the movie theater, you know, half a mile away was bustling, no one was around these stores. And so I'm just taking turn after turn,
所以我逃跑了，在商业街区飞驰。那是一个非常拥挤的区域，有很多大型连锁店。我完全惊慌失措。我根本不知道要去哪里。而且，再次强调，天很黑。周围没有人。尽管电影院，你知道，半英里外就是。周围没有人，尽管电影院，你知道，半英里外很热闹，但这些商店周围没有人。所以我只是不停地转弯，
and he's getting closer and closer on my tail. And eventually I turn into a parking lot of like a Home Depot store. And he, you know, revs and gets close to me and I turn and I go behind this store into the loading dock. And so there's a steep embankment on my right. So I'm really like funneled into this little canyon with this guy behind me.
他离我越来越近，紧追不舍。最终我转进了一个像家得宝（Home Depot）商店的停车场。他，你知道，加速靠近我，我转弯并绕到这家商店后面的装卸区。右边有一个陡峭的堤岸。所以我真的被困在这个小峡谷里，后面跟着这个家伙。
And he accelerates up beside me and then in front of me and starts kind of like cutting me off. And he accelerates up beside me and then in front of me and starts kind of like cutting me off. He kind of like corrals me into the wall, kind of into a corner. And I realized I was trapped. Kurt was so paralyzed with fear, he could barely think. And he gets out of his car and starts walking towards me. Again, very menacing, he's very angry.
他加速到我旁边，然后在我前面，开始像切入我的车道一样。他加速到我旁边，然后在我前面，开始像切入我的车道一样。他把我逼向墙边，困在一个角落里。我意识到我被困住了。库尔特被恐惧麻痹了，几乎无法思考。他从车里出来，开始向我走来。再次强调，非常具有威胁性，他非常生气。
And all my friends, we were talking on the way there, obviously we were having fun, deadly silent, no music. My one friend in the back who's thinking lucidly, her name is Jessie, she says, lock the door. And so I immediately locked the door, and a second later he grabs my handle and just starts to haul on the handle trying to pull me out of the car.
我们所有的朋友，我们在去那里的路上还在聊天，显然我们玩得很开心，现在死一般的寂静，没有音乐。坐在后座的一个朋友，她思维清晰，名叫杰西，她说，锁上车门。于是我立刻锁上了车门，一秒钟后他抓住我的把手，开始猛拉，试图把我从车里拽出来。
Wow, but the door is locked at this point, so he can't get in. Exactly, but I also realize I have to diffuse the situation because he's so angry and much bigger than me. And so I do the only thing I can, because he's so angry and much bigger than me. And so I do the only thing I can, which is, you know, start to apologize. So I unroll my window a few inches.
哇，但此时车门锁着，所以他进不来。没错，但我也意识到我必须化解这种情况，因为他太生气了，而且比我强壮得多。所以我做了我唯一能做的事，因为他太生气了，而且比我强壮得多。所以我做了我唯一能做的事，那就是，你知道，开始道歉。所以我把车窗摇下几英寸。
I say, I'm so sorry. I know it's my fault. I wasn't watching where I was going. And he again says, you know, you're dead. I'm gonna kill you. And then he reaches into, you know, through the crack in the window and he tries to unlock the door
我说，我非常抱歉。我知道是我的错。我没注意看路。他又说，你知道，你死定了。我要杀了你。然后他把手伸进，你知道，穿过车窗的缝隙，试图从里面
from the inside with his hand. Wow. And so I'm simultaneously trying to stay calm and contrite, apologize to this man while frantically slapping away his hand so he can't unlock the door. And then it's clear he's not gonna be able to unlock it. And so he just starts slapping me
用手打开车门。哇。所以我同时试图保持冷静和悔悟，向这个人道歉，同时疯狂地拍打他的手，这样他就无法打开车门。然后很明显他无法打开车门。于是他开始隔着车窗缝隙
through the crack in the window, he's grabbing me by my collar and just kind of shaking me, just repeating like I'm gonna kill you, you're dead again and again. How does this end? The friend of mine in the backseat, Jesse, you know, the cogent one, her mom happened to work for a cell phone store.
拍打我，他抓住我的衣领，不停地摇晃我，一遍又一遍地重复说我要杀了你，你死定了。这怎么收场？坐在后座的朋友杰西，你知道，那个清醒的人，她的妈妈恰好在一家手机店工作。
And cell phones back when I was in high school were not popular, not everyone had one, but she had one lent from her mom just in case anything, anything happened if she had to make any phone calls. And it was a, you know, a kind of brick of a phone as the old ones were. And she holds it up and she says to this guy, I've got a cell phone and I'll call the cops. And so this doesn't sink in right away to the guy who keeps on slapping me and threatening
在我上高中的时候，手机并不普及，不是每个人都有，但她从她妈妈那里借了一部，以防万一发生任何事情，如果她需要打任何电话的话。那是一部，你知道，像砖头一样的手机，就像旧式的那种。她把它举起来，对这个家伙说，我有手机，我会报警。所以这并没有立刻让那个不停拍打我并威胁
to kill me. And then eventually he stops, it sinks in, and he takes his hand away and he kind of bends down and he looks through the crack in the window he takes his hand away, and he kind of bends down, and he looks through the crack in the window at all of us in the car, and he says, fine, you call the cops, and I'll tell them what you did. And this statement was perplexing to me, because clearly in my mind,
要杀我的人冷静下来。然后最终他停了下来，他意识到了，他把手拿开，弯下腰，透过车窗的缝隙看着我们车里的所有人，他说，好，你们报警吧，我会告诉他们你们做了什么。这句话让我感到困惑，因为在我的脑海里，
if I explain what had happened to the police, they would surely be on my side. I was the one getting assaulted, getting threatened with murder, but I was puzzled because he was so confident that the police would be on his side. I couldn't understand how he could be so confident that he was in the morally right position. And yet I was confident that I was morally correct. I think when things like this happen to us, we're very quick to try and defend
如果我向警察解释发生了什么，他们肯定会站在我这边。我是那个被袭击、被威胁要杀害的人，但我很困惑，因为他如此自信警察会站在他那边。我不明白他怎么能如此确信自己处于道德正确的位置。然而我也确信我是道德正确的。我认为当这样的事情发生在我们身上时，我们很快就会试图捍卫
our particular points of view. But as you're telling me the story, I'm an observer, and I can see things from both points of view. I can see how he must have been driving along the road. Someone swerves in front of him at high speed, nearly kills him, and he says, clearly, I'm the victim here. This crazy teenager could have killed me. And from your point of view, you're saying, you know, I made a mistake,
我们特定的观点。但当你给我讲这个故事时，我是一个观察者，我可以看到双方的观点。我可以看到他当时一定是在路上开车。有人高速冲到他前面，差点杀了他，他会说，显然，我是这里的受害者。这个疯狂的少年差点杀了我。而从你的角度来看，你说，你知道，我犯了一个错误，
a simple mistake, and I'm really sorry about it, but surely that mistake doesn't warrant somebody chasing me through dark streets for mile upon mile, cornering me and threatening to kill me. I agree. And as I started to do research on moral psychology, I came more and more to recognize the genuine concerns that he had about being harmed.
一个简单的错误，我真的很抱歉，但这个错误肯定不值得某人穿过黑暗的街道追我好几英里，把我逼到角落并威胁要杀我。我同意。当我开始研究道德心理学时，我越来越认识到他对于受到伤害的真实担忧。
He genuinely felt like he was victimized and so did I. And so this presented a puzzle to me. We experienced the same situation and had completely opposite perceptions of blame and harm. I have to ask you what happened that night after your friend threatened to call the police and he said, go ahead, call them. How did the incident come to an end? Well, he, after he told us to go ahead and call the cops, he kind of stood there and
他真诚地觉得他受到了伤害，我也是。所以这对我来说是一个谜。我们经历了同样的情况，却对指责和伤害有着完全相反的看法。我必须问你，那天晚上你的朋友威胁要报警，他说，去吧，报警吧，之后发生了什么？这件事是怎么结束的？嗯，在他告诉我们去报警之后，他站在那里，
looked at us for a while and maybe recognized that we were all frightened teenagers you know, trapped in a little metal cage like Ville in some parking lot. And he stormed back to his car, slammed his door and squealed off into the night. When we come back, how Kurt's story speaks to our deep political divides. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
看了我们一会儿，也许意识到我们都是受惊的青少年，你知道，被困在停车场里一个小金属笼子里。他冲回他的车，猛地关上车门，尖叫着消失在夜色中。当我们回来时，库尔特的故事如何说明我们深层的政治分歧。你正在收听Hidden Brain。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. At the University of North Carolina, Chapel Hill, psychologist Kurt Gray studies the science of political polarization. Along with other researchers who study how we think about our political opponents, Kurt finds that we make a series of assumptions and draw a series of conclusions about people who disagree with us politically. These assumptions and conclusions are especially powerful because they happen so swiftly, automatically and unconsciously that they don't feel like assumptions or conclusions. They feel like facts, self-evident facts. The first of these has to do with what we think is happening inside our opponent's minds, or rather, what we think isn't happening inside our opponent's minds.
我是Shankar Vedantam。这是Hidden Brain。我是Shankar Vedantam。在北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校，心理学家库尔特·格雷研究政治极化的科学。与其他研究我们如何看待政治对手的研究人员一起，库尔特发现，我们对那些在政治上与我们意见不一的人做出一系列假设并得出结论。这些假设和结论非常强大，因为它们发生得如此迅速、自动且无意识，以至于它们感觉不像假设或结论。它们感觉像是事实，不言自明的事实。其中第一个与我们认为对手头脑中正在发生什么有关，或者更确切地说，我们认为对手头脑中没有发生什么。
We generally think that we, our side, is smart, that we vote in our own self-interest and that we do things that make sense. And we think that we want policies that are gonna help ourselves and the country. But when we think of our opponents, we think of them as being quite stupid. We think of them as not voting in their own self-interest and we think of them not wanting policies
我们通常认为我们，我们这一方，是聪明的，我们为了自己的利益投票，我们做的事情是有道理的。我们认为我们想要有助于我们自己和国家的政策。但当我们想到对手时，我们认为他们很愚蠢。我们认为他们没有为了自己的利益投票，我们认为他们不想要
that's gonna help them. And so in one study we did in North Carolina, we presented people with a bunch of amendments that were part of an election a few years ago, and we just asked people about those amendments and why someone on the other side might vote differently than they do on those amendments. And so it might ask a progressive participant in North Carolina, why might a conservative person vote yes on these things? And what we found is that people think
有助于他们的政策。因此，在我们北卡罗来纳州的一项研究中，我们向人们展示了多年前选举中的一系列修正案，我们只是询问人们关于这些修正案的问题，以及为什么另一方的人可能会在这些修正案上投出与他们不同的票。所以可能会问北卡罗来纳州的一位进步派参与者，为什么保守派人士可能会对这些事情投赞成票？我们发现的是，人们认为
that people on the other side, they think that they are dumb and they don't appreciate what's best for themselves or their country or the state. So in other words, we think the other side is filled with sheeple. Exactly. We think that we are thoughtful and rational and doing the best we can with complex issues. And we also think that those on the other side
另一方的人，他们认为他们很笨，他们不欣赏什么对自己、国家或州最有利。换句话说，我们认为对方充满了“羊群”。没错。我们认为我们是深思熟虑和理性的，正在尽我们所能处理复杂的问题。我们也认为另一方
are not those things at all. They are tricked by the media, they are deceived by some leader, that they are sheeple, and we just think that they're stupid. So we think our opponents are not very smart, but it's also the case that we feel like we don't like our opponents very much, but we think our opponents have stronger feelings about us.
根本不是那样。他们被媒体欺骗了，被某个领导人欺骗了，他们是“羊群”，我们只是认为他们很蠢。所以我们认为我们的对手不太聪明，但事实也是，我们觉得我们不太喜欢我们的对手，但我们认为对手对我们有更强烈的感情。
Tell me about the work you've done looking at how we think about our opponents and how we think our opponents feel about us. So it's true that we don't like folks on the other side, but a lot of research finds that we severely overestimate how much the other side dislikes us. In one paper, the researchers show that we inflate our estimates of how much the other side dislikes us by somewhere between 50 to 300%. Wow. So, Republicans might mildly dislike Democrats in general, but if you ask Democrats how much you think Republicans dislike you, they think it's this deep burning hatred to yourself and your political party.
告诉我你所做的工作，研究我们如何看待对手，以及我们认为对手如何看待我们。所以确实我们不喜欢另一方的人，但许多研究发现，我们严重高估了另一方讨厌我们的程度。在一篇论文中，研究人员表明，我们将另一方讨厌我们的程度估计夸大了50%到300%。哇。所以，共和党人可能在总体上轻微不喜欢民主党人，但如果你问民主党人你认为共和党人有多讨厌你，他们认为这是一种对你和你所属政党的深层燃烧的仇恨。
And it's just not true. And of course, the reverse is true as well, that Republicans believe that the Democrats hate them. And I understand that this work, I think it was done by Samantha Moore-Berg in 2020, found that the more partisan people are, the more strongly partisan people are, the more they hold this bias. That's right. So no matter what side of the political spectrum you are, the further out on that spectrum you are, the more you inflate your estimates
这根本不是真的。当然，反过来也是如此，共和党人认为民主党人讨厌他们。我知道这项工作，我想是Samantha Moore-Berg在2020年做的，发现党派色彩越浓的人，党派色彩越强烈的人，他们越持有这种偏见。没错。所以无论你在政治光谱的哪一边，你在那个光谱上走得越远，你就越夸大你的估计
of how much the other side hates you. I'm wondering what the effect of this is. If you and I are in conflict with one another and we have a disagreement about something, I can tell myself, Kurt wants X and I want Y, and we can figure out, is there a middle ground between X and Y? But if I tell myself, Kurt doesn't just want X, Kurt can figure out, you know, is there a middle ground between X and Y. But if I tell myself, you know, Kurt doesn't just want X, Kurt actually hates me and really
关于另一方有多恨你。我想知道这有什么影响。如果你和我发生冲突，我们对某事有分歧，我可以告诉自己，库尔特想要X，我想要Y，我们可以弄清楚，X和Y之间是否有中间地带？但如果我告诉自己，库尔特不仅仅想要X，库尔特可以弄清楚，你知道，X和Y之间是否有中间地带？但如果我告诉自己，你知道，库尔特不仅仅想要X，库尔特实际上恨我，并且真的
wants the worst for me. It becomes very difficult to think about splitting the difference between X and Y. That's right. So compromise and democracy more generally requires that we're willing to talk with others who might disagree with us, cooperate with others who might disagree with us. And if you think the other side hates you, it can be hard to even engage in conversation with them. It's a fight for survival.
想要我遭遇最坏的情况。思考在X和Y之间折中变得非常困难。没错。所以妥协和民主更广泛地要求我们愿意与可能不同意我们的人交谈，与可能不同意我们的人合作。如果你认为另一方恨你，甚至很难与他们进行对话。这是一场生存之战。
I'm thinking back to that incident that took place when you were a teenager, the incident where you got into a conflict with another driver. And one of the things that strikes me is that in that moment when your friend was threatening to call the police, you felt righteous because you felt clearly, I'm the one who has been wronged here and the police will see my side of the story. And the other driver felt righteous too and said, surely the police will see my side of the story. And the other driver felt righteous too and said, surely the police will see my side of the story. In some ways, when we believe that people will hate us, it gives us license to feel righteous.
我回想起你十几岁时发生的那件事，你与另一位司机发生冲突的那件事。让我印象深刻的一点是，当你的朋友威胁要报警时，你感到正义，因为你觉得很明显，我是那个被冤枉的人，警察会看到我的故事版本。而另一位司机也感到正义，并说，警察肯定会看到我的故事版本。在某种程度上，当我们相信人们会恨我们时，它给了我们感到正义的许可。
Absolutely right. We feel righteous and in the moral right because not only are we hated, but also because we're being harmed, right? There's a villain on the other side. They're attacking us, and that makes us the victim. And when we're feeling victimized, we feel licensed to protect ourselves
绝对正确。我们感到正义和道德正确，不仅因为我们被恨，还因为我们受到了伤害，对吧？另一方有一个恶棍。他们在攻击我们，这使我们成为受害者。当我们感到受害时，我们觉得有权保护自己
in any way that we can. I'm wondering how much of this is about, you know, what psychologists sometimes call cognitive closure, seeking cognitive simplicity. If I have to say, Kurt wants X, I want Y, what's the middle ground? It's complicated. But if I can just say, Kurt hates me, Kurt is clearly wrong, I'm in the right. In some ways, it's cognitively simpler.
以任何我们可以的方式。我想知道这在多大程度上是关于，你知道，心理学家有时所说的认知闭合，寻求认知简单化。如果我必须说，库尔特想要X，我想要Y，中间地带是什么？这很复杂。但如果我能只说，库尔特恨我，库尔特显然是错的，我是对的。在某种程度上，这在认知上更简单。
Yes. Our minds want simplicity. And that's especially true when it comes to morality. And the reason is because if we acknowledge that the moral universe is complicated, then we have to acknowledge that our moral beliefs might sometimes be wrong. And so when I was in that car,
是的。我们的思维想要简单。当涉及到道德时尤其如此。原因是因为如果我们承认道德世界是复杂的，那么我们就必须承认我们的道德信仰有时可能是错误的。所以当我在那辆车里时，
recognizing that the other driver had a legitimate, you know, a genuine feeling of victimhood meant that I might be the villain. I might be the perpetrator there. And that's a tough pill to swallow. So we've looked at how we believe that our opponents are stupid and that our opponents hate us. You say that another belief that we hold about our opponents is whether they care about democracy and they care about our shared civic values.
认识到另一位司机有一种合法的，你知道，一种真实的受害者感，意味着我可能是那个恶棍。我可能是那里的肇事者。那是一个很难接受的事实。所以我们已经看了我们如何相信我们的对手是愚蠢的，我们的对手恨我们。你说我们对对手持有的另一个信念是他们是否关心民主以及他们是否关心我们共同的公民价值观。
Talk to me about this research, Gert. A team of scientists has found that although people generally support democracy, everyone in America generally supports democracy, we vastly overinflate how much people on the other side don't want to support democracy. So our side is pro-democracy, their side is, if not anti-democracy, at least willing to let democracy slide to win at politics.
跟我谈谈这项研究，库尔特。一组科学家发现，尽管人们通常支持民主，美国每个人通常都支持民主，但我们极大地夸大了另一方的人有多么不支持民主。所以我们这一方是支持民主的，他们那一方，如果不是反民主的，至少是为了在政治上获胜而愿意让民主滑坡。
That perception means that now we feel threatened, now we're in a war, they're trying to destroy democracy. And so in a war, we have to fight dirty too. And the perception that the other side is anti-democratic licenses our side to also do anti-democratic things. Because they're willing to steal elections for us to even stay in the game, we should be willing to bend the rules as well. That's right. I'm wondering what you make of recent events in the United States.
这种看法意味着现在我们感到受到威胁，现在我们处于战争中，他们正试图摧毁民主。所以在战争中，我们也必须进行肮脏的战斗。而认为另一方是反民主的看法，许可我们这一方也做反民主的事情。因为他们愿意为了让我们甚至留在游戏中而窃取选举，我们也应该愿意打破规则。没错。我想知道你对美国最近发生的事件有什么看法。
So, for example, if you think about the January 6th insurrection, how would you think about that? I think many Democrats would look at that and say, you know, very clearly these are people who actually try to overturn the election. Clearly they are anti-democratic. It's not just a perception in my head. So the January 6th example is a great one
所以，例如，如果你想到1月6日的叛乱，你会怎么想？我想许多民主党人会看着它说，你知道，很明显这些人实际上试图推翻选举。很明显他们是反民主的。这不仅仅是我脑子里的一个看法。所以1月6日的例子是一个很好的例子
because from the outside, it seems like these are the folks who are just trying to destroy democracy. But I think from the outside, it seems like these are the folks who are just trying to destroy democracy. But I think from the inside, if you look at it from their perspective, they think that they are upholding democracy because they were led to believe that the election was stolen. And maybe what they're doing isn't democratic, but if they thought that Democrats kind of fired the first shot, they're just retaliating. But in that case, there is a difference between what everyday people think and what political elites are doing.
因为从外部看，看起来这些人只是试图摧毁民主。但我认为从外部看，看起来这些人只是试图摧毁民主。但我认为从内部看，如果你从他们的角度看，他们认为他们是在维护民主，因为他们被引导相信选举被窃取了。也许他们所做的事情不是民主的，但如果他们认为民主党人开了第一枪，他们只是在报复。但在那种情况下，普通民众的想法和政治精英正在做的事情之间是有区别的。
So I think when it comes to the behavior of the many people who went up to the capital on January 6th. It's easy to see how their worldview supports the idea that they are standing up for democracy and for freedom. I'm not sure that I would be as sympathetic to some elites who are propagating that idea. So we've looked at how people think the other side is stupid, the other side is irrational, the other side is anti-democratic. You recently published a study, Kurt, that reported on what Democrats and Republicans
所以我认为当谈到1月6日去国会大厦的许多人的行为时。很容易看出他们的世界观如何支持他们正在为民主和自由挺身而出的想法。我不确定我是否会像同情一些正在传播这种想法的精英那样同情他们。所以我们已经看了人们如何认为另一方是愚蠢的，另一方是不理性的，另一方是反民主的。库尔特，你最近发表了一项研究，报告了民主党人和共和党人
in the United States believe about one another when it comes to topics such as murder, child pornography, and embezzlement. Tell me about the study. Yeah, so that study, I should say, it's not yet published, but it is available online, all the data and the manuscript. And in that study, we wondered how people would view the morality of the other side. And of course, we already know that progressives and conservatives disagree about hot button issues. So you might think the other side is wrong about abortion,
在美国，当涉及到谋杀、儿童色情和贪污等话题时，他们是如何看待彼此的。告诉我这项研究。是的，那项研究，我应该说，它还没有发表，但它可以在网上找到，所有的数据和手稿。在那项研究中，我们想知道人们会如何看待另一方的道德。当然，我们已经知道进步派和保守派在热门问题上存在分歧。所以你可能认为另一方在堕胎问题上是错的，
about capital punishment or immigration, but there are many moral issues that seem totally uncontroversial, like murder or embezzlement, or as you say, child pornography. And so the question is, what do people think about those and the other side when it comes to those issues?
关于死刑或移民，但有许多道德问题似乎完全没有争议，比如谋杀或贪污，或者正如你所说，儿童色情。所以问题是，当涉及到这些问题时，人们如何看待那些问题和另一方？
Would Republicans think Democrats are okay with child pornography or embezzlement or infidelity and so forth and vice versa? So when we look at the data, we find that consistent with what we'd been talking about before, people vastly overestimate how much those on the other side see these obvious moral wrongs as acceptable. We show that both Democrats and Republicans think that 15% of the other side view child
共和党人会认为民主党人可以接受儿童色情或贪污或不忠等等，反之亦然吗？所以当我们看数据时，我们发现与我们之前讨论的一致，人们极大地高估了另一方在多大程度上认为这些明显的道德错误是可以接受的。我们表明，民主党人和共和党人都认为15%的另一方认为儿童
pornography as acceptable. That's crazy. The real answer is basically zero, but we really inflate how much the other side is evil and lacks a basic moral sense. So I mean, we're in really deep waters here because now our dislike for one another is not just about policy matters and we're not even dressing it up as being about policy matters. We're actually saying our opponents now are just evil people who are bent on just destroying
色情是可以接受的。这太疯狂了。真正的答案基本上是零，但我们确实夸大了另一方有多邪恶以及缺乏基本的道德感。所以我的意思是，我们在这里处于非常深的水域，因为现在我们对彼此的厌恶不仅仅是关于政策问题，我们甚至没有把它包装成关于政策问题。我们实际上是在说我们的对手现在只是邪恶的人，一心只想摧毁
the world. So I think this rampant polarization makes people endorse something that we call a destruction narrative, where the other side is motivated by the urge to destroy our side and also America. And it's really the sense that the other side wants to watch the world burn. I should say that people think that the other side is more stupid than evil, you know, more misguided than demonic.
世界。所以我认为这种猖獗的极化使人们支持我们称之为“毁灭叙事”的东西，即另一方受到摧毁我们这一方以及美国的冲动的驱使。这确实是一种感觉，即另一方想看着世界燃烧。我应该说，人们认为另一方是愚蠢多于邪恶，你知道，被误导多于恶魔。
But it's still not a great place to be, obviously. And there's still a sense that the other side is motivated by some destruction. That when the other side passes some policy with some unintended negative side effect, as all policies have, some research shows that people think that those on the other side intend those negative policy consequences. That they want to hurt people on the other side. But of course that's not true. Folks are just trying to do the best they can when it comes to these policy preferences. So we've talked in different ways and offered different examples of how in our political
但这显然仍然不是一个好的处境。而且仍然有一种感觉，即另一方受到某种毁灭的驱使。当另一方通过某种带有某种意想不到的负面副作用的政策时，正如所有政策都有的那样，一些研究表明，人们认为另一方打算产生那些负面的政策后果。他们想伤害另一方的人。但当然那不是真的。当涉及到这些政策偏好时，人们只是在尽他们所能。所以我们以不同的方式谈论并提供了不同的例子，说明在我们的政治
discourse we want to see ourselves as being the victim, as being potentially harmed, and seeing the other side as the perpetrator, the other side as the villain, the people who are trying to do us harm. And of course, the other side feels exactly the same way. But it raises a really interesting point, which is that the animating force in much of politics might not be animosity and aggression,
话语中，我们想把自己看作是受害者，是潜在的受害者，并把另一方看作是肇事者，另一方是恶棍，是试图伤害我们的人。当然，另一方也有完全相同的感觉。但这提出了一个非常有趣的点，即政治中许多的推动力可能不是敌意和侵略，
but it might be a feeling of victimhood, a feeling that we are under siege, that we are under attack. Can you talk about this idea? Because I think that's not the way most people think about politics. So that people think about politics as being a, you know, blood sport, very aggressive. But the picture that you're painting, I think,
而可能是一种受害者感，一种我们处于围困中，我们受到攻击的感觉。你能谈谈这个想法吗？因为我认为这不是大多数人思考政治的方式。所以人们认为政治是一项，你知道，血腥运动，非常有侵略性。但我认为你描绘的画面
is slightly at odds with that, where the feelings of vulnerability that we have are in fact the dominant drivers of our perceptions and behavior. That's right. So when we think about the motivations of others, we think that they are aggressive. We think that they are trying to destroy us. We think they are motivated by some deep instinct to hurt us.
与此略有不同，我们拥有的脆弱感实际上是我们感知和行为的主要驱动力。没错。所以当我们思考他人的动机时，我们认为他们是侵略性的。我们认为他们正试图摧毁我们。我们认为他们受到某种伤害我们的深层本能的驱使。
But my reading of the literature and my work suggests that ultimately people are motivated by this desire to protect themselves, to guard against threats, they're motivated by a sense of vulnerability. So rather than a destruction narrative, I think the politics is better described by a protection narrative, where people are trying to protect themselves and their vulnerabilities. Where do you think this comes from, this sort of constant need to protect ourselves, to see ourselves as under threat?
但我对文献的解读和我的工作表明，最终人们受到这种保护自己的欲望的驱使，以防范威胁，他们受到一种脆弱感的驱使。所以与其说是毁灭叙事，我认为政治最好用保护叙事来描述，人们试图保护自己和他们的脆弱性。你认为这来自哪里，这种不断保护自己的需要，把自己看作是受到威胁？
Where do you think this comes from, Kurt? I think our desire to protect ourselves from threat in politics and the modern world comes from way back in human nature. I think that the human experience and the modern world comes from way back in human nature. I think that the human experience is ultimately an experience of threats and fear and worry about our vulnerabilities.
你认为这来自哪里，库尔特？我认为我们在政治和现代世界中保护自己免受威胁的欲望来自人类本性的深处。我认为人类的经验和现代世界来自人类本性的深处。我认为人类的经验
I'm wondering, Kurt, if some people might say, you know, that can't possibly be true. Humans are at the apex of the planet right now. You know, every other species should fear humans because in fact we are the most deadly predator on the planet right now. But you're making the case that humans in fact are motivated almost entirely by fear, by vulnerability.
最终是一种威胁、恐惧和对我们脆弱性的担忧的经验。库尔特，我想知道，如果有些人可能会说，你知道，那不可能是真的。人类现在处于地球的顶端。你知道，其他所有物种都应该害怕人类，因为事实上我们是目前地球上最致命的捕食者。但你正在论证人类事实上几乎完全受到恐惧、脆弱性的驱使。
There seems to be a mismatch there. There is a mismatch and there is no doubt that today we are apex predators. We can hunt wolves from helicopters. We can remake the world. But there is a fallacy in thinking that just because we are predators today that that's how we have always been. And in fact, if you look back in the midst of time, where our minds and our human nature
这里似乎有一个错位。确实有一个错位，毫无疑问，今天我们是顶级捕食者。我们可以从直升机上猎杀狼。我们可以重塑世界。但认为仅仅因为我们今天是捕食者，这就是我们一直以来的样子，这是一个谬论。事实上，如果你回顾时间的迷雾，我们的思维和我们的人性
evolved, we were not predators at all. Instead, we were prey. We evolved not as predators, but as prey. I understand that you had an incident in your own life that brought home to you your own vulnerability as an individual creature. Tell me the story of what happened, Kurt. Before I wanted to be a social psychologist, I thought I wanted to be a geophysicist.
进化而来，我们根本不是捕食者。相反，我们是猎物。我们进化的不是作为捕食者，而是作为猎物。我知道你自己的生活中发生过一件事，让你意识到自己作为一个个体生物的脆弱性。告诉我发生了什么，库尔特。在我想要成为社会心理学家之前，我以为我想成为一名地球物理学家。
And a geophysicist spends a lot of time outdoors in remote locations looking for natural gas or oil. And so I was very far north. So if you drive to the border between Montana and Alberta, and you drive 18 hours straight north, and then you turn left and drive for another hour, you come to Rainbow Lake, Alberta. And then from Rainbow Lake, which is extremely isolated,
而地球物理学家花很多时间在偏远地区的户外寻找天然气或石油。所以我当时在非常北的地方。所以如果你开车到蒙大拿州和阿尔伯塔省的边界，然后你直向北开18个小时，然后你左转再开一个小时，你就到了阿尔伯塔省的彩虹湖。然后从彩虹湖，那里非常孤立，
you take a helicopter ride another 30 miles into the bush. That's where we were looking for natural gas. So there was a crew of five of us, four college students, and one old man named Ian, who was at the time 25, but he seemed like an old man to us. And we would spend our days in the middle of the wilderness, driving around on snowmobiles and pounding stakes into the ground to try to find natural gas. On one of these expeditions, Kurt and his team had just finished a tough day's work.
你乘坐直升机再飞30英里进入丛林。那就是我们寻找天然气的地方。所以我们有一个五人的团队，四个大学生，还有一个叫伊恩的老人，他当时25岁，但在我们看来他像个老人。我们会在荒野中度过我们的日子，骑着雪地摩托到处转，把木桩钉进地里试图寻找天然气。在这些探险中的一次，库尔特和他的团队刚刚结束了一天艰苦的工作。
But before the helicopter could come fetch them, bad weather rolled in. The helicopter pilot told them he'd come get them the next morning. But it was winter and it was very cold. And the five of us were literally in the middle of nowhere and had no water, no food, except some leftover sandwiches from lunch and we had to spend the night alone in the middle of the Canadian wilderness. And so we went off to the forest, we built a lean-to, we gathered some firewood, we lit it with gasoline, which I wouldn't recommend unless that was your only source of anything flammable in the middle of the wilderness.
但在直升机来接他们之前，恶劣的天气卷土重来。直升机飞行员告诉他们他第二天早上会来接他们。但那是冬天，非常冷。我们五个人真的在荒郊野外，没有水，没有食物，除了午餐剩下的三明治，我们必须在加拿大荒野中独自过夜。所以我们去了森林，我们建了一个窝棚，我们收集了一些木柴，我们用汽油点燃了它，除非那是你在荒野中唯一可燃的来源，否则我不建议这样做。
And then we just sat down to wait through the night until the helicopter might be able to come and pick us up. And I'm assuming it was pitch... apart from the fire, it was pitch dark. It was pitch dark. It was minus 10 degrees Celsius. We had no other blankets. We had no other jackets other than our one-piece fire retardant No-Mex coveralls. You know, we weren't prepared to weather a night outside. So we shared the remnants of our lunch. We sat around the fire talking, and then it was time to go to bed. And so we all, five in a row, we spooned with each other to stay warm,
然后我们只是坐下来等待整晚，直到直升机可能能够来接我们。我假设那是漆黑的……除了火光，那是漆黑的。那是零下10摄氏度。我们没有其他毯子。除了我们的一件式阻燃No-Mex工作服外，我们没有其他夹克。你知道，我们没有准备好在户外过夜。所以我们分享了午餐的残余。我们围坐在火堆旁聊天，然后是睡觉的时间了。所以我们五个人排成一排，互相依偎着取暖，
but that proved to be too cold in the night. And so we eventually found our way back to the fire and we curled up around it in a circle and tried to sleep while the flames were high and while we were warm. And then when the flames died down, we would wake up and we'd add some wood to the fire and try to sleep again.
但这在夜里证明太冷了。所以我们最终回到了火堆旁，围成一个圈蜷缩起来，试图在火焰高涨和我们温暖的时候睡觉。然后当火焰熄灭时，我们会醒来，往火里加些木头，试图再次入睡。
And we did that for 10, 12 hours. Now, obviously, there's no human predators out there, but presumably there are animals. Before this night, I had never thought about predators. I grew up in a city in Canada, but there was a couple times when I woke up in the middle of the night where I felt uneasy. And you might say, of course you felt uneasy because you were stuck in the middle of the wilderness hoping not to die, you know, of cold or thirst or something like that. But I just couldn't get the sense that you know there was something out there and you it's so dark
我们那样做了10到12个小时。显然，外面没有人类捕食者，但想必有其他动物。在那晚之前，我从未想过捕食者的问题。我在加拿大的一座城市长大，但有几次我在半夜醒来时感到不安。你可能会说，当然会不安，因为你被困在荒野中央，祈祷自己不会死于寒冷、口渴之类的东西。但我就是无法摆脱那种感觉，你知道，外面有什么东西，而且天太黑了。
You can't see beyond this little circle of light so you could look into the woods and there was absolutely nothing but blackness And it's not like there's some serial killer out there, right? It's not like a horror movie because we're so far from civilization, but I still got this uneasy sense. And then bit by bit, the sky turns gray, it's still pretty cloudy out. And we get up and we stretch, and as we walk around the campsite, we notice that there are paw prints all the way around, very close to where we were sleeping.
你看不见那小圈光亮之外的地方，所以你望向树林时，除了漆黑一片什么也看不见。这又不是什么恐怖电影，外面也不会有连环杀手，对吧？因为我们离文明世界太远了，但我还是有一种不安的感觉。渐渐地，天空变灰了，外面依然阴云密布。我们起身伸展身体，在营地周围走动时，发现周围全是爪印，离我们睡觉的地方非常近。
They were lynx paw prints. What had happened in the night was that some lynx had hurt us, had smelt us, and had crept close to us in the night. For our overseas listeners who live in tropical climates, can you tell me what they are? Links are big fluffy bobcats. I don't think they could take down an adult man, but I think they could probably eat a small child and certainly they could rip out the throat of someone who's sleeping in the darkness. And that realization hit home to me as we sat there in the morning waiting to get picked up by the helicopter.
那是猞猁的爪印。那天晚上发生的事情是，有猞猁闻到了我们的气味，并在夜里悄悄靠近了我们。对于我们那些生活在热带气候地区的海外听众，你能告诉我它们是什么吗？猞猁是大而毛茸茸的短尾猫。我不认为它们能打倒一个成年男子，但我认为它们很可能会吃掉一个小孩子，而且肯定能撕开在黑暗中熟睡之人的喉咙。当我们坐在那里等待直升机接我们时，这种认识让我深受触动。
And we couldn't have done anything to prevent it because humans are weak and we don't have nails and we don't have teeth. And if there had been a real predator, if it had been a mountain line, then we wouldn't have stood a chance. Not very long ago, this was not unusual at all. 150 years ago and earlier, stuff like this happened probably all the time in all parts of the world. People were living in close proximity to nature and in fact were vulnerable in ways that we
我们当时什么也做不了，因为人类很脆弱，我们没有利爪，也没有尖牙。如果当时真的有捕食者，比如是一只美洲狮，那我们就毫无胜算了。不久前，这种情况一点也不罕见。150年前及更早的时候，这种事在世界各地可能时有发生。人们与自然近距离共处，事实上，我们在某些方面是脆弱的，而我们
simply don't feel today. Absolutely. So for the last millions of years of our evolution, we have been vulnerable to predation. And it's really only in the last 100, couple hundred years that that threat has basically dropped down to zero for most of us. For a long time, people were hunted by wolves, tigers, bears. But even today, in our industrialized world,
今天根本感觉不到。绝对是这样。在过去数百万年的进化过程中，我们一直容易受到捕食。直到最近的一两百年，对于我们大多数人来说，这种威胁才基本降为零。很长一段时间里，人们一直受到狼、老虎和熊的捕食。但即使在今天，在我们工业化的世界里，
many people are still vulnerable to predators. There was a case in Canada several years ago of a pop singer going for a walk through Nova Scotia Forest, and she was killed and partially eaten by a pack of coyotes. I'm wondering what effect this has on our minds, the fact that in some ways we've had a very long evolutionary history where we are vulnerable and potentially under threat, and a very recent evolutionary history where that threat has receded, what has that done to our minds, Kurt? Our longstanding vulnerability to predation has really shaped our psychology in our modern world.
许多人仍然容易受到捕食者的威胁。几年前在加拿大发生过一起案件，一位流行歌手在诺瓦斯科舍省的森林里散步时，被一群郊狼杀害并部分吃掉。我在想，这会对我们的思想产生什么影响？事实上，在某种程度上，我们有着非常漫长的进化史，期间我们一直处于脆弱和潜在的威胁之下，而最近的进化史中这种威胁又消退了，这对我们的思想产生了什么影响，库尔特？我们长期以来对捕食的脆弱性确实塑造了我们现代世界的心理。
Even if we don't think about predators today very much, we are still fundamentally concerned with protecting ourselves from threats. And those threats might not be sitting in the forest or in the jungle behind our houses, but we are constantly bombarded with threats today when it comes to politics, when it comes to morality. So we bring forward this long-standing evolutionary feeling of threat into our modern political realm. And this is why we typecast the other side as predators. And I think it's important to recognize this because fundamentally those folks on the other side who we see as
即使我们今天不太考虑捕食者，我们仍然从根本上关注如何保护自己免受威胁。这些威胁可能并不存在于我们屋后的森林或丛林中，但今天我们在政治和道德方面不断受到威胁的轰炸。因此，我们将这种长期存在的进化而来的威胁感带入了现代政治领域。这就是为什么我们将对方定型为捕食者。我认为认识到这一点很重要，因为从根本上说，那些我们视为
predators also feel like prey. Even the other driver in the parking lot that night, he felt like the victim, like the prey. Of course that doesn't mean that liberals and conservatives have to define harm the same way. What you might consider harmful might not necessarily be what I consider harmful, which is why we can be worried about different issues. That's exactly right. So in my research, we find that liberals might emphasize harms to the environment,
捕食者的人，也觉得自己是猎物。那天晚上停车场里的另一位司机，他也觉得自己是受害者，是猎物。当然，这并不意味着自由派和保守派必须以同样的方式定义伤害。你认为有害的事情，未必是我认为有害的事情，这就是为什么我们会担心不同的问题。完全正确。所以，在我的研究中，我们发现自由派可能强调对环境的伤害，
or they might emphasize harms to members of disadvantaged groups, whereas conservatives might emphasize harms to social order, to those trying to protect our society like police, and perhaps to religious entities like God or the Bible. like police and perhaps to religious entities, like God or the Bible. You can see this very well even with hot button issues, like immigration.
或者他们可能强调对弱势群体成员的伤害，而保守派可能强调对社会秩序的伤害，对那些试图保护我们社会的人（如警察）的伤害，以及可能对宗教实体（如上帝或圣经）的伤害。就像警察，或者可能对宗教实体，如上帝或圣经。即使在移民等热门话题上，你也能很好地看出这一点。
So progressives might worry about the harm done to undocumented immigrants, who they perceive as vulnerable, whereas conservatives might worry about the harm done by undocumented immigrants who might be criminals or drug traffickers in America. So both of those positions are motivated by a desire to protect us from harm. They disemphasize competing harms in that issue. It's a problem we face in nearly every dimension of our lives. Our brains were sculpted by evolution over thousands of years.
进步派可能担心对无证移民造成的伤害，他们认为这些移民是弱势群体，而保守派可能担心无证移民造成的伤害，他们可能认为这些人是罪犯或毒贩。因此，这两种立场都是出于保护我们免受伤害的愿望。他们在该问题上淡化了相互冲突的伤害。这是我们在生活几乎每个层面都面临的问题。我们的大脑是经过数千年的进化塑造而成的。
Our minds today are the product of those evolutionary forces. We are walking around with machines that were designed, if you will, in the Stone Age. Unsurprisingly, there are mismatches between what those brains were designed to do and the challenges we confront today. When we come back, how understanding the psychology of our political conflicts can help to bridge seemingly intractable divides. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan.
我们今天的思想是这些进化力量的产物。可以说，我们带着在石器时代设计出来的机器四处走动。不出所料，这些大脑的设计初衷与我们今天面临的挑战之间存在错位。稍后回来，我们将探讨了解政治冲突的心理学如何帮助弥合看似难以调和的分歧。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹坦。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. Psychologist Kurt Gray studies the science of political polarization. In a number of studies, he and other researchers have found that Democrats and Republicans in the United States and partisans in other countries have very strong and very wrong views about their opponents. We tend to think our opponents are idiotic and irrational. That's the mild stuff. We also think they're anti-democratic, evil, and are okay with children being harmed.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹坦。心理学家库尔特·格雷研究政治极化的科学。在多项研究中，他和研究人员发现，美国的民主党人和共和党人，以及其他国家的党派人士，对他们的对手有着非常强烈且非常错误的看法。我们倾向于认为我们的对手是愚蠢和非理性的。这还算温和的。我们还认为他们反民主、邪恶，并且对伤害儿童无动于衷。
We ask ourselves, what is wrong with those people? How can any decent person have such terrible and misguided thoughts? Our certitude about our moral superiority means we don't have to understand our opponents or give them the benefit of the doubt. So you've done a lot of work, Kurt, sort of looking at ways in which we can turn down the temperature on political polarization. And you say that one of the first and most practical things that we can do is to frame our positions on issues in terms of harm.
我们问自己，这些人怎么了？任何正派的人怎么会有如此可怕和误导性的想法？我们对自身道德优越性的确信意味着我们不必去理解我们的对手，也不必给他们留有余地。所以，库尔特，你做了很多工作，试图寻找缓解政治极化的方法。你说我们可以做的第一件也是最实际的事情之一，就是从伤害的角度来构建我们在问题上的立场。
So in other words, we think that facts are what bridge divides, but in fact, it's our shared concern about harm that actually is what bridges divides. That's right. And we have a big paper with 15 studies that shows that people think that facts are the key to bridging divides. But when you actually give people facts in heated conversations about morality, it doesn't work. Instead, what does work to Bridge divides is allowing people to talk about their own concerns with harm, to talk about their own worries about threats and the pain that they or their family may have suffered. And that makes them seem less like sheeple. It makes them seem less stupid and less evil, even though they disagree with you. They have the same concerns about harm, so they're similar to you, but it also makes sense that they would make this decision. And so now they're not
换句话说，我们认为事实是弥合分歧的关键，但事实上，我们对伤害的共同担忧才是真正弥合分歧的东西。没错。我们有一篇包含15项研究的大型论文，表明人们认为事实是弥合分歧的关键。但当你真的在激烈的道德对话中向人们提供事实时，它并不起作用。相反，真正能弥合分歧的是让人们谈论他们自己对伤害的担忧，谈论他们对自己所面临威胁的忧虑，以及他们或家人可能遭受的痛苦。这让他们看起来不那么像“乌合之众”。这让他们看起来不那么愚蠢和邪恶，即使他们不同意你的观点。他们对伤害有同样的担忧，所以他们和你很相似，而且他们做出这个决定也是有道理的。所以现在他们不是
voting against their own self-interest. They're not being irrational. What they do makes sense, and that makes people willing to respect them and have conversations with them. Kurt, one of the things you say is that it's important for us to remind ourselves that the other person's feelings about harm are genuine. Even if those feelings of harm seem unfounded to us, why is this hard to do that the authenticity of other people's perceptions of harm, especially when those perceptions are opposite to our own. And that's because our perceptions of harm are deeply intuitive. We feel them in our gut when you, if you're a pro-choice person Thinking about the abortion debate in your gut, you know, it's about protecting women But if you're a pro-life person then in your gut, you know, it's about protecting unborn children and
在违背自己的利益投票。他们并非不理性。他们的所作所为是有道理的，这使得人们愿意尊重他们并与他们交谈。库尔特，你说过很重要的一点是，我们要提醒自己，对方对伤害的感受是真实的。即使这些伤害感在我们看来毫无根据，为什么做到这一点很难？尤其是当这些对他人的伤害感知与我们自己的感知相反时。这是因为我们对伤害的感知是深刻直觉的。我们从内心深处感受到它们。如果你是一个支持堕胎选择权的人，在内心深处思考堕胎辩论时，你知道，这是为了保护女性。但如果你是一个反堕胎的人，那么在内心深处，你知道，这是为了保护未出生的孩子，并且
The power of those intuitions about harm make it difficult to realize that the other person is authentically trying to protect someone from harm. But it's so crucial because that's what we need to do to recognize that those on the other side are motivated by protection and not destruction. You also talk about an idea called moral humility, which you say is different from intellectual humility. Yeah. There's been a lot of discussion these days about intellectual humility, and I think it's important to recognize that you might be wrong about how the world works. But it's much harder to think that your moral judgments might not be 100% right. We are deeply motivated to think that, you know, we are good people. And yet moral
这些关于伤害的直觉力量使得人们很难意识到对方是在真诚地试图保护某人免受伤害。但这至关重要，因为我们需要认识到，对方阵营的人是出于保护而非破坏的动机。你还谈到了一个叫“道德谦逊”的概念，你说它与“智力谦逊”不同。是的。最近关于智力谦逊的讨论很多，我认为认识到你可能对世界的运作方式有误是很重要的。但要认为你的道德判断可能并非百分之百正确，这就难得多了。我们有强烈的动机去认为，你知道，我们是好人。然而，道德
humility is appreciating that even if we are good people, other people might be good too. And even if they disagree with us, they're still good. And so what that means is that we might not be 100% right about our moral judgment, and it's hard to have that kind of humility. I want to talk about a demonstration of moral humility that was in a recent documentary called Guns and Empathy. It was produced by a nonprofit organization called Narrative 4 in partnership with New York Magazine.
谦逊是认识到，即使我们是好人，其他人也可能是好人。即使他们不同意我们的观点，他们依然是好人。这意味着我们对道德判断可能并非百分之百正确，而拥有那种谦逊是很难的。我想谈谈最近一部名为《枪支与同理心》的纪录片中展示的道德谦逊。它是由一家名为Narrative 4的非营利组织与《纽约杂志》合作制作的。
And during this documentary, one of the participants was a woman named Carolyn Tuft, who was shot three times in a mass shooting at a mall in Salt Lake City, and her 15-year-old daughter was killed. I want to play you a little clip of what Carolyn said. Everything I knew is gone. If people thought that could happen to them and thought they could actually lose their business, lose their house, lose their family,
在这部纪录片中，其中一位参与者是一位名叫卡罗琳·塔夫特的女性，她在盐湖城一家购物中心发生的大规模枪击事件中身中三枪，她15岁的女儿被杀。我想给你播放一小段卡罗琳说的话。我所知道的一切都消失了。如果人们认为这种事可能发生在他们身上，认为他们真的会失去生意、失去房子、失去家人，
I think that gun would not have so much hold. And a little while later, Kurt, there was another person who spoke at the same event. Her name was Jillian Weiss, and she had a very different view on guns. She was born with a disability, and she bought a pistol after she was stalked, and after she learned that disabled women were much more likely to be sexually assaulted than women without disabilities. Let me play you a clip of Jillian. I have my gun with me in my home and I feel so much safer knowing that should anything happen, I can defend myself.
我想枪支就不会有那么大的吸引力了。不久之后，库尔特，在同一活动上还有另一个人发言。她的名字叫吉莉安·韦斯，她对枪支有着非常不同的看法。她天生残疾，在被跟踪后买了一把手枪，因为她了解到残疾女性比非残疾女性更容易受到性侵犯。让我给你播放一段吉莉安的片段。我的家里有枪，知道如果发生任何事情，我可以保护自己，这让我感到安全得多。
What is the effect of hearing these two different stories on people who are listening? What's happening in their minds? on people who are listening. What's happening in their minds? Listening to these stories might not persuade you, but it does make you see the position of the person telling these stories as rational, as something that makes sense, and it makes you respect that position,
听到这两个不同的故事对听众有什么影响？他们的脑子里在想什么？在听众的脑子里。听这些故事可能不会说服你，但它确实让你看到讲述这些故事的人的立场是理性的，是有道理的，这让你尊重那个立场，
and makes you willing to interact more with that person. And those feelings of respect and the willingness to engage are essential in our pluralistic democracy. We depend on compromise, on open dialogue in our society. And so these stories of harm are a good first step at motivating the kind of respect that we need to decrease polarization and increase our willingness to engage with others.
并让你愿意与那个人进行更多互动。这种尊重感和参与的意愿在我们多元化的民主社会中至关重要。我们依赖于妥协，依赖于社会中的公开对话。因此，这些关于伤害的故事是激发我们所需的尊重感的一个很好的第一步，以减少极化并增加我们与他人接触的意愿。
It often seems to many people, Kurt, that the divides that we have in our country and many countries around the world are so intractable, so painful, that it can seem as if there is no way out. There are no solutions out, that there's no hope in sight. And I think that's understandable because the temperature has been turned up to such a pitch. But you cite a historical example of a moment when people put aside their differences and truly saw the humanity of the other side. And it occurred in 1914 in the First World War.
库尔特，对许多人来说，我们国家和世界许多国家存在的分歧似乎总是如此难以调和，如此痛苦，以至于看起来似乎没有出路。没有解决办法，看不到希望。我认为这是可以理解的，因为矛盾已经被激化到了极点。但你引用了一个历史例子，当时人们抛开了分歧，真正看到了对方的人性。这发生在1914年的第一次世界大战中。
Can you tell us what happened? It was the first Christmas of the First World War. Can you tell us what happened? It was the first Christmas of the First World War. And, you know, the sides were dug in in their trenches. They had the barbed wire up. And even though they were supposed to be killing each other, as Christmas approached, they started being kinder killing each other, as Christmas approached, they started being kinder to each other, right? They would hear each other singing Christmas carols
你能告诉我们发生了什么吗？那是第一次世界大战的第一个圣诞节。你能告诉我们发生了什么吗？那是第一次世界大战的第一个圣诞节。你知道，双方都深陷在战壕里。他们架起了铁丝网。尽管他们本应互相残杀，但随着圣诞节的临近，他们开始变得更友善，随着圣诞节的临近，他们开始变得更友善，对吧？他们会听到对方唱圣诞颂歌，
in the trench over and might wave at each other, right? Shout some pleasantries. And eventually the situation got so positive that the Germans and the Allies decided to have a soccer game in No Man's Land where they exchanged gifts. And so this is really an act of defiance against the generals who wanted them to kill each other. And it was an act of camaraderie and bridging divides that I think is remarkable even today.
在战壕那边，可能会互相挥手，对吧？喊几句客套话。最终，情况变得如此积极，以至于德国人和盟军决定在“无人区”进行一场足球比赛，并交换了礼物。所以这确实是对那些希望他们互相残杀的将军们的反抗。这是一种同志情谊和弥合分歧的行为，我认为即使在今天也令人瞩目。
Their mission was to literally murder each other, and yet they found space to come together and see past their disagreements. I think it holds powerful, applicable lessons for our own time. The elites in our government and in the media are telling us to hate each other and telling us that we should hate each other, but we already know from all the scientific work we talked about today that the other side actually doesn't hate us as much as we think.
他们的任务是字面意义上的互相残杀，但他们却找到了空间走到一起，看透了他们的分歧。我认为这对我们这个时代有着强大且适用的教训。我们政府和媒体中的精英们告诉我们要互相仇恨，告诉我们应该互相仇恨，但我们从今天讨论的所有科学研究中已经知道，对方实际上并不像我们想象的那样仇恨我们。
And so this should be an inspiration that even in war, real war, people can rise up and come together and we can too. Kurt Gray is a psychologist and neuroscientist at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill. He plans to publish a book about these ideas in 2025. The book is going to be titled Outraged, Why We Fight Over Morality and Politics. Kurt, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. Have you tried to talk with someone who disagrees with you about politics?
所以这应该是一种激励，即使在战争中，真正的战争中，人们也能站起来走到一起，我们也可以。库尔特·格雷是北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校的心理学家和神经科学家。他计划在2025年出版一本关于这些想法的书。书名将是《愤怒：为什么我们为道德和政治而战》。库尔特，非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你的邀请。你是否尝试过与在政治上不同意你的人交谈？
Have you found effective ways to get through? Have you lost friends over political disagreements? If you'd be willing to share your stories with the Hidden Brain audience, along with any questions you have for Kurt Gray, please record a voice memo and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line politics. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristin Wong, Laura Quirelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew
你是否找到了有效的沟通方式？你是否因为政治分歧而失去了朋友？如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享你的故事，以及你对库尔特·格雷的任何问题，请录制一段语音备忘录并发送电子邮件至ideas@hiddenbrain.org。再次重复那个电子邮件地址，是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。再次重复那个电子邮件地址，是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。请使用主题行“政治”。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁
Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Next week in our Us 2.0 series, the mistakes we make when we try to change someone's mind and a better way to talk to political opponents. Asking somebody to give up their moral values, people are willing to fight and die for their values, right? Like, people really, really are invested in not changing their minds about that.
查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。下周在我们的“我们2.0”系列中，我们将探讨当我们试图改变某人的想法时所犯的错误，以及与政治对手交谈的更好方式。要求某人放弃他们的道德价值观，人们愿意为他们的价值观而战甚至牺牲，对吧？就像，人们真的、真的投入其中，不愿改变他们的想法。
I'm Shankar Vedantan. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹坦。很快再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。